MINHAZ KAZI: Welcome
to "DataVis DevTalk."
I'm your host, Minhaz
Kazi, developer advocate
for Data Studio.
In this episode of
"DataVis DevTalk,"
you will learn how to manage
versions of your connector code
and how to use separate
deployments for your connector.
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
As you develop code for
your Community Connector,
you can test and use your
connector in Data Studio
by deploying it
from Apps Script.
Deployments let Data Studio
execute the connector code
by Apps Script.
You can access and manage all
deployments for your connector
by going to the Publish
menu and selecting Deploy
From Manifest in the
Apps Scripts environment.
After selecting
this option, you'll
see the list of all available
deployments for your connector.
For a new connector
project, you'll
start with the head deployment.
This head deployment
will always be associated
with the current or latest
version of your code
that you're working with.
Click on any deployment to
reveal the deployment link.
You or your users can use this
link to directly access and use
your connector in Data Studio.
If you go to your
deployment link,
it will open up your Data Studio
with your connector selected.
If this is the first time
you're using a connector,
Data Studio will ask
for authorization
for that connector.
This is where you can start
testing your connector.
The other way to
test your connector
is to view the deployment
list in Apps Script
and get the idea for deployment.
Next, open up Data
Studio in a browser tab
and go to data sources.
Start adding a new data source
and click on the developers
icon on top right.
This will give you
an interface where
you can enter the connector
ID, validate the deployment,
and then select the
connector to start using it.
This method is helpful to
evaluate how your connector
card might look like in the
Data Studio connector gallery.
I mentioned earlier that the
head deployment is always
associated with the latest
version of your connector code.
Apps Script lets you save
different versions or snapshots
of your code.
These snapshots are
numbered sequentially,
and you can add your own
notes to each version
as you make the changes.
Let's say you're
developing a connector
and you want a few
colleagues to try it out.
However, at the
same time, you want
to keep working on the code.
So you save a new
version of your code,
we'll call it Test Candidate
1, and create a new deployment
based on this version.
We'll call this deployment Test.
This test deployment will
have a different deployment ID
and deployment URL compared
to your head deployment.
After your colleagues
try out your connector,
they give you some feedback
and you update your code.
This new version of the code
is now called Test Candidate 2.
Now, you want to
integrate these changes
into the test deployment
so your colleagues can
view the changes.
You don't have to create
a new deployment here.
You can just edit the
existing test deployment
and select the new version
of the code to use.
Having multiple
deployments and the ability
to update the version
of the code associated
with each deployment
helps you to have
a streamlined
deployment process.
We strongly recommend that
you use the head deployment
only during code development.
Use separate test and
production deployments
for testing and distribution
of your connector.
There are a few things to
keep in mind for deployments.
First, connectors in Data
Studio are associated
with unique deployment links.
So if you create two deployments
from your connector code
and add them to
Data Studio, they
will appear as two
separate connectors.
Second, you can edit
and update the name
for the deployment and the
version of the code associated
with the connector.
But you cannot edit a
deployment ID or link.
And third, if you delete a
deployment from Apps Script,
it cannot be recovered.
Let's say your users are
using a specific deployment
and have created
dashboards from it.
If you delete the
deployment from Apps Script,
the connector and the associated
dashboards will stop working.
To learn more about
deployments and versions,
check out the links in
the description below.
And don't forget to
subscribe to the GCP channel
for more great content
on Data Studio.
Thanks for watching.
And until next time, keep
building awesome dashboards.
[MUSIC PLAYING]